they say being in nature is good for the
soul when it is on this Veterans Day
some Chicago area vets are proving it is
true they're benefiting from a unique
program inside a Botanic Garden we're
tending to plants also helps them tend
to the lingering wounds of war
Adriana Diaz has the story the Chicago
Botanic Garden has a new crop of
unlikely green thumbs I'm like what am I
getting myself into I'm a military guy
veterans like Steve Joseph who says he
was skeptical at first when he heard he
could get paid to learn about flowers in
the gardens internship program for vets
what is this boat garden about I come to
the gate and that gate was like wow what
took his breath away
wasn't the beauty it was the gardens
effect on his PTSD something
psychologists call horticultural therapy
I lost some friends there another storm
in his 20 years in the Navy Joseph's
deployed five times and saw dozens of
friends die I relive those incidents in
my head every day so the garden kind of
puts that in peace when I walked through
the when I walked through the front gate
it really puts my mind at ease it takes
away the darkness and brings some
lightness you just have migraines all
the time and I'm down to one or two a
month and I think that's due to poor in
part to to come to work in the garden
there is different the feelings
different I don't have to be on guard
here Chadwick Minh served in the Army
setting up communications he was
homeless for most of the last decade
drugs and alcohol were his escape from
what he calls a military mentality of
always being on alert that's training
yeah do that for years on end and not
stop and have to drink to avoid that
yeah I had to say I'd not cut my
drinking down tremendously since working
here psychological and physical trauma
make it difficult for some vets to hold
jobs nearly half a million are
unemployed the ones interning here learn
new skills attend job readiness
workshops
receive therapy from their surroundings
in a way they can't quite explain I
don't know how to say it I'm not really
sure how it works I just know that to
being around nature very good for the
soul
occupational therapists Barbra kreski
says nature's mysterious ability to heal
is firmly rooted in science what is
pretty solid now is evidence that
spending time in nature decreases
measures of stress hard to measure it's
not just I feel better
cortisol levels heart rate sweat I don't
care who you are people respond to
plants kreski runs the program and says
vets make the best interns without
exception spectacular okay you do not
serve a military term and come out a
slacker you just don't have you seen
them transform yes yes it's like walking
meditation you can't help being happy
here
they served in different Wars and fight
different battles within themselves but
these vets all say they now breathe a
little easier for CBS this morning
Saturday Adriana Diaz Chicago growing
things is good for the soul I love what
we departed dad always said that it is
so true I don't care who you are she
said people respond to plants